guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live version of the
minimalists podcast
and i want to invite you to join us for
a night of less find your nearest city
at the minimalists comm / tour we'll see
you there our our desires tied to our
fears and vice versa
i mean let's talk about fear here
because it does seem to me - to a great
extent maybe our fears often fuel our
desires or it could also stunt them -
right like my fear of going snowboarding
I could have absolutely allowed that to
just stunt my love for snowboarding but
I'm the type of but I'm the type of
person though where it does fuel me
though in the sense that I'm fearful of
something I'm like oh I got to go out
and face that head-on and I'm gonna see
if I can conquer it but I could see
where a lot of people they want to go to
the party and they want to be outgoing
but they're so scared of what people are
gonna think that they kind of like shove
that desire down and don't do I think
they still have the desire though they
just don't take action on it I mean
maybe the desire can go away at some
point but it seems to me Pete that that
when we when we're afraid of something
it often well it's certainly tied to our
desires yeah there's something going on
there I mean a simple example is this
has happened to me I was at a party
recently there was a guy there we got
talking and he was telling me that he
was terrified of death had a real fear
of death and it was something that
actually paralyzed him a lot of times in
his life and as we were talking he
because he's also tried to find
solutions to this and and but we were
chatting and I was kind of like going
well here you know what what if what if
you're not afraid of death what if
you're obsessed with it
and and actually it's your what what
you're afraid of is your desire just
like if you look over a cliff and you
feel like you want to jump you know you
feel like that because there's so your
fear jumping because there's something
in you that wants to jump so I live in
the 31st floor of an apartment and I
have this window that opens up and it
has a plastic kind of barrier so you
can't fall right but you can't see it is
clear plastic so I'll often whenever
someone comes up I'll see if they can
like like put their hands behind their
back and fall against the plastic you
know so but it's interesting how some
people are terrified of even go I mean
it's not a small nice thing to do to
people but down or some people are
terrified of going near to the window
even sure you know it's it not
everybody's then interested in death but
but sometimes if you've got that fear of
falling it actually shows that you have
a fear you have a death Drive a fear of
death so that that's an example of hi
and it was funny cuz talking to him it
did she inches perspective like he did
as we talked he was like actually there
is a part of me that wants to die and he
was like and so because because here he
was asking me because he knows that I'm
interested in his ideas and he was going
hard I overcome my fear of death and
what I talked him what is gonna no it's
not about overcoming your fear of death
you never will what you have to do is
look at your desire to die and as you
make peace with that desire and as you
work it through the fear of death will
disappear you're trying to get rid of
the fear of death work work through your
desire and as you work through your
desire the fear will disappear